in the summer sunshine it's easy to see
the attraction of living on the north
norfolk coast but it's home to one age
group in particular
one in three people who live here are 65
or older
and moved here when she was 80 and
hasn't looked back
every other person is retired
and they all
walk their dogs or walk themselves along
the front here every day and i think it
keeps us all healthy
the census results give us a snapshot of
how the population is changing and it
was carried out at an interesting time
in march of last year so after brexit
and right in the midst of the pandemic
there are now more over 65s than ever
before
18.6
in england the places with the most over
65s are here in north norfolk and rather
in east sussex while east devon has the
most over 90s making up nearly 2 of the
population there
why is the population aging and what
challenges does that bring
this um all stems from the baby boomers
after the second world war so it's that
population group that in this sense has
moved into
pensionable ages and the census results
are really really important for being
able to determine where those older
populations are so that we can plan the
right services in the right places
russell simpson is a dementia support
worker here in chroma he sees the other
side to what many would consider an
idyllic place to retire
it's people who may
be diagnosed with dementia and their
carers
being a bit
marooned really in small villages around
norfolk
with problems with transport challenges
with transport because they may no
longer be able to drive
as time passes the needs of people here
will only grow
a chance now for places like this to
plan how best to support them
becky johnson sky news in chroma